[Music]
Okay, let's get started.
[Music] [Music
]
What's going on? You're
so distracted. [Music] That's
why Ono Kusama doesn't bring out any weapons and is so motivated. You're just
like I said from now on.
Don't do it.  Asa-san
must have been seduced by that guy, and so am I. All of a sudden they're talking about things like battles and gods that don't make
any sense.
Well, there's no need to fight. There's
no need to go to the extent of killing each other.  That's why I'm so
stupid.
[Music] You're
so vulgar, so vulgar, so crazy. But I'm
not doing it because someone told me to. The battles I
choose to fight are like
gods.  People like you who have it all and
don't think about anything, let's do it together
[music]